Nous reprenons cette série sur Galates.
Nous avons observé une transition très importante dans la lettre,
où dans les chapitres 5, l'apôtre Paul va se concentrer plus sur ce qu'on appelle la sanctification.
Donc, nous ne devrions jamais séparer l'ensemble de l'œuvre du salut ou de la rédemption,
même car, comme on est en train de voir, la Bible nous enseigne de manière très claire
que c'est possible que les personnes qui croient être sauvées ne les soient pas,
mais c'est impossible que ceux qui sont vraiment sauvés perdent leur salut.
Et donc, la rédemption est une œuvre complète.
Voilà pourquoi la Bible nous dit que les Christs sont l'auteur et les consommateurs de notre foi,
que celui qui a commencé l'œuvre en nous va l'amener à terme.
Cette assurance, elle est biblique,
mais c'est vrai que pour comprendre les développements de notre salut
ou les déroulements de notre rédemption,
nous pouvons identifier certaines emphases dans la Bible
où elle ne va pas provoquer une séparation entre l'œuvre de la rédemption,
mais elle va nous montrer des phases, des moments distinctes,
des facettes, si vous voulez, qui nous aident à comprendre ces phénomènes surnaturels
qui ont eu lieu dans nos vies au moment de notre conversion.
Et donc, il y a une distinction essentielle qui fait la différence entre les saluts,
la conversion, la genèse ou les débuts de la foi,
et la maintenance du salut, les développements du salut,
si vous voulez, la sanctification ou la persévérance des saints.
OK ?
Donc, Paul, l'apôtre, dans la lettre Galate,
il se voit devant une menace grotesque contre la compréhension réelle de l'Évangile,
car ça, c'est absolument nécessaire pour que nous soyons sauvés.
Si nous ratons dans la compréhension essentielle l'Évangile,
il n'y a pas de salut pour personne,
car pour plus que la conversion soit une réalité expérimentale,
pour chacun de nous individuellement,
elle est quelque part aussi les résultats
ou elle est dépendante d'une œuvre objective qui a été faite par Jésus-Christ.
C'est-à-dire, il a eu une provision, attention,
pour une justice qui nous manquons,
qui a été objectivement pourvue par les fils des dieux lorsqu'il est venu sur terre.
Dieu a envoyé son fils pour vivre une vie parfaite à notre place,
pour souffrir à la croix la punition qu'on méritait.
Ça, c'est une œuvre objective complète faite d'une fois pour toutes dans les passés.
Ma participation dans cette œuvre ne peut avoir aucune possibilité
d'être une participation réelle,
si ce n'est qu'est par la foi seule,
indépendamment de mes efforts religieux.
Donc, quelle est la conversion ?
L'apôtre Paul, il fait beaucoup d'efforts
dans la plupart de la lettre aux Galates,
dans la plus grande portion,
jusqu'à la fin du chapitre 4,
presque en train de mettre toute l'emphase sur le fait
que nous ne pouvons qu'être sauvés,
être déclarés dans les tribunaux des dieux comme complètement justes,
si par la foi, nous sommes associés à Jésus-Christ.
C'est-à-dire, on prend les Christ en tant que représentants légaux,
et par la foi, on s'associe à lui,
on s'est présent devant les tribunaux des dieux
avec Christ comme bouclier, quelque part,
en disant, voici ma justice.
Tous les péchés que je devrais payer,
souffrir pour l'éternité à l'enfer,
ont été déversés sur lui à la croix,
et il a vécu une vie parfaite à ma place
pour m'écréditer son obéissance parfaite.
Donc, Paul a traité cette problématique
par rapport à la conversion,
les débuts de la foi.
Et là, l'apôtre Paul,
il a aussi fait beaucoup d'emphase tous les longs de la lettre,
même si plus d'emphase a été donnée
sur être déclaré juste au début de la foi,
par la foi,
tout le long de la lettre,
il gardait quand même une emphase
sur le fait que Dieu n'a jamais déclaré juste
ce qu'il n'a pas rendu juste.
Donc, qu'est-ce qu'il voulait dire par là ?
C'est que l'œuvre de la conversion ou de la rédemption
dans son intégralité n'est pas séparable.
Et ceux qui, devant les tribunaux des dieux,
ont été déclarés comme justes
car ils ont placé leur foi en Jésus-Christ,
ils sont nés de nouveau.
Ils sont morts pour eux-mêmes,
pour leur ancienne vie,
une vie de péché, d'esclavage,
et ils sont nés pour Dieu.
Si vous voulez,
on était comme des tisons
lancés dans le feu de l'enfer,
et on a été régénérés ou ressuscités,
on a été pris comme une branche
qui était déjà presque brûlée,
et on a été greffés à cette vigne
de pleine vitalité qu'elle est Christ.
Et donc, dans la conversion,
nous ne sommes pas qu'à déclarer juste,
on est greffés à Christ,
il n'y a pas qu'à une déclaration légale
devant un tribunal pour sortir de là
avec un document,
Christ est ma justice,
mais il y a une transformation de notre nature.
Nous sommes nés de nouveau.
Le Saint-Esprit est celui qui opère en nous,
cette régénération,
c'est par son esprit qu'on est connecté à Christ la vigne,
et c'est impossible que par cette transformation radicale
au niveau du cœur,
nous ne progressions pas en sanctification.
Donc, tous les développements de la foi
sont assurés par les moments de la conversion
si la conversion a été réelle.
Si la conversion a été réelle,
ces greffages, si vous voulez,
ou l'effet d'avoir été greffés à Christ,
c'est un changement définitif pour toujours.
Étant greffé à Christ,
la caractéristique de la vie chrétienne,
c'est un développement progressif
en sanctification,
sauf que ce développement
n'est pas une diagonale croissante constante.
C'est plutôt une espèce d'oscillation
envers la sainteté,
car pour plus que notre liberté soit en liberté réelle,
cette liberté n'est pas en liberté complète aujourd'hui.
Donc, nous sommes faits enfants de Dieu,
mais nous sommes en train d'être faits
progressivement enfants de Dieu
en conformité à Christ.
On est déjà devenus radicalement enfants de Dieu,
mais nous devons encore
nous nettoyer des restes de la pollution du péché,
cette chair qui agit encore
contre nos membres spirituels,
mais cette chair qui est déjà crucifiée,
qui a souffert un coup mortel
et qui sera de plus en plus moins active
et l'esprit,
avec notre nouvelle nature,
qui progresse.
Donc ça, c'est un résumé
de ce qu'on a déjà compris
entre la distinction entre conversion
et sanctification,
début de la foi
et continuité de la foi.
Et c'est important de nous rappeler,
c'est en phase biblique
qui commence au verset 1
et qui est renforcée au verset 13
du chapitre 5.
Au verset 1, nous avons cette déclaration,
c'est pour la liberté
que Christ nous a affranchis.
Ce qui est très important à remarquer,
c'est la distinction entre finalité
et la conception des conquêtes
ou des conditions.
Donc là, le texte est en train de dire
c'est avec la finalité
que vous réjouissez d'une liberté
que Christ vous a affranchis.
C'est-à-dire, on était avant
dans une condition de complète esclavage,
impossible de plaire Dieu
dans notre esclavage de péché
condamné par la loi.
Mais Christ nous a affranchis
par son œuvre parfaite.
Sauf qu'il ne nous a pas affranchis,
attention,
voilà verset 1,
demeurez donc ferme
et ne vous laissez pas mettre
de nouveau sous les jouges
de la servitude.
Donc d'un côté,
les principales ennemies d'épaule
dans l'église des Galates,
c'était les judaïsants.
Donc ce qu'il est en train de dire,
c'est pour la liberté
que Christ vous a affranchis.
Attention,
d'avoir été délivré
du poids des menaces,
des condamnations de la loi,
c'est ressenti qu'on avait
avant la conversion d'un Dieu
contre nous.
Et cette tentation
d'émener une vie légaliste
envers Dieu,
c'est-à-dire en voulant
transpirer par la religion
pour conquérir l'amour de Dieu,
ça, c'est un esclavage
de notre vie passée
lorsqu'on était esclaves du péché
et incapables d'accomplir la loi.
Pourvu que Christ a accompli
la loi parfaitement
à notre place
et qu'il nous a transformés,
notre relation avec Dieu
n'est plus une relation
sous les menaces,
c'est une relation filiale,
c'est une relation de liberté,
c'est-à-dire moi,
si je suis vraiment converti,
je vais librement vouloir
plaire Dieu,
vouloir que Dieu
vit dans ma vie
à travers ma vie.
Et donc,
c'est qu'il est en train de dire,
attention aux judaïsants,
cette mauvaise influence
entre vous
qui veut suggérer
que vous pouvez perdre
les saluts
et donc vous devez transpirer
pour maintenir votre salut.
La vie des sanctifications,
c'est une vie des libertés.
Liberté pour être
tel qu'est Dieu.
enfant des dieux.
Liberté pour avancer
en sanctification,
pour vivre une vie d'amour.
De l'autre côté,
au verset 13,
il va attaquer
l'autre menace.
Frère,
vous avez été appelé
à la liberté,
seulement ne faites pas
de cette liberté
en prétexte
de vivre selon la chair.
Donc,
la liberté doit être comprise
comme
une obéissance
volontaire
à la loi
avec un cœur d'enfant
qui veut plaire
les pères.
Mais de l'autre côté,
la liberté
ne peut pas être perçue
perçue
comme
l'opposition
à une opposition
à cette mentalité
légaliste
qui veut performer
pour conquérir
l'amour des dieux
ou pour maintenir
le salut.
Mais ce n'est pas
une opposition
qui va dans la direction
de la carnalité.
Ah,
si je suis complètement
pardonné
et si mon obéissance
est toujours volontaire,
les personnes vont
se lancer dans les péchés.
Et c'est ce que Paul
est en train de dire.
Non,
c'est pour la liberté
qui vous avait été enfranchie.
Et voilà pourquoi
au verset 13,
il dit
vous avez été appelé
à la liberté.
La liberté ne peut pas
être comprise
comme la liberté
pour pécher.
C'est la liberté
du péché.
Vous comprenez ?
Donc,
les Galates,
ils ne sont sous aucune menace
s'ils sont vraiment chrétiens.
S'ils sont vraiment
nés de nouveau,
ils sont nés pour Dieu,
ils sont morts
pour la chair
et leur vie
va naturellement
par leur union vitale
avec les Christs
par les Saint-Esprits,
ils vont marcher
dans la direction
de la volonté des dieux
volontairement.
Vous voyez ?
Les conflits ici,
c'est cette conception tordue
de la sanctification
que nous avons dans nos jours
où nous avons plutôt
l'impression
que pour nous sanctifier,
nous devons toujours
aller contrairement
à nos plaisirs,
à nos volontés.
Les vrais plaisirs,
la vraie volonté fondamentale
du chrétien,
c'est de plaire Dieu,
c'est de se sanctifier.
Comme dit D.I. Packer
dans son livre
dans les mêmes pas
avec le Saint-Esprit,
il va dire
que de la même manière
que dans nos jours,
dans les mondes,
si jamais on entend
les mots sexe
dans une salle
avec beaucoup de personnes,
plusieurs personnes
vont regarder
vite fait
celui qui parle.
C'est un mot électrisant,
on dit comme ça.
Pour les vrais chrétiens,
ces mots,
c'est sainteté.
Il dit,
pour les vrais chrétiens,
lorsqu'ils entendent
les mots sainteté,
il est attentif.
Il a envie
de comprendre
comment il peut avoir
cette sainte obsession
satisfaite,
comment il peut progresser
dans la foi.
Et donc,
c'est la description
que nous allons retrouver
lorsque nous arrivons
au verset 16.
Car,
la correction
qu'Paul va apporter
aux Galates
qui sont sous cette menace
d'avoir vécu
cette déroute
dans leur foi
où ils avaient
bien commencé,
ils avaient reçu
une nouvelle nature,
n'est pas,
attention,
une liste
des tâches
à accomplir.
Ce n'est pas
des nouvelles expériences
très mystiques
quelque part,
des révélations,
des nouvelles vérités
qu'on ne connaissait pas.
Par exemple,
je ne dois pas être
à l'attente
que quelqu'un me dise
que je dois faire attention
à l'Internet
dans une réunion
de prière
et de révélation.
si la Bible,
elle est claire
pour que je sois
en train de faire attention
contre la passion
de la chair
qui m'amène
à la immoralité sexuelle,
je ne dois pas
atteindre
une révélation.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Ce que Paul
va présenter
comme source
fondamentale
et basique
pour maintenir
et progresser
dans la sanctification,
c'est un rappel
de ce que nous sommes.
La question,
à nouveau,
n'est pas
si je peux perdre
mon salut,
c'est sujet
vraiment sauvé,
sujet vraiment
né de nouveau.
Donc,
l'exhortation
de Paul,
c'est plus ou moins
revenez à être
ce que vous êtes,
revenez à marcher
tel que vous marchiez
au départ
avant de souffrir
cette interception,
cette mauvaise influence
que vous avez vécue.
Et donc,
il dit
de manière très impérative,
marchez selon l'esprit
et vous n'accomplirez pas
les désirs de la chair.
Donc,
très impératif,
marchez.
Donc,
si un impératif,
c'est comme Augustin,
il priait à Dieu
avant la conversion,
donne-moi
la chasse
t'étais,
mais pas maintenant.
Ici,
c'est le contraire.
C'est à partir
du moment
où Dieu nous présente
une exigence,
c'est car il a déjà
pourvu la puissance
pour l'accomplir.
Donc,
l'impératif,
c'est marchez
selon l'esprit
et vous n'accomplirez
point les désirs
de la chair.
Donc,
attention,
les restes de la chair
sont encore là,
voilà pourquoi
elle fait appel,
elle présente ses désirs.
Par contre,
remarquez bien,
qu'est-ce que Paul
va décrire à propos
de la nouvelle nature
du chrétien ?
Car la chair
a des désirs
contraires à ceux
de l'esprit.
Au verset 24,
il dit que la chair
est déjà crucifiée
dans le passé
avec ses passions
et donc,
c'est une force
qui est un désavantage
par rapport
à notre nouvelle nature
et aux puissances
qui sont à notre disposition.
Donc,
il y a les saints esprits
qui nous ont régénérés
pour vivre pour Dieu.
Nous avons une nouvelle volonté
et nous sommes aidés
donc par les tout-puissants
saints esprits
couplés à une volonté
prédominante,
fondamentale,
nouvelle,
plaire Dieu,
être saint.
Mais il y a cette résistance
qui est une guerre réelle.
Et là,
la chair
a des désirs
contraires
à ceux de l'esprit.
L'esprit en a des
contraires à ceux
de la chair.
Ils sont opposés
entre eux
afin qu'ils vous
n'effaciez
point ce que vous voudriez.
Faire ce que vous voudriez
veut dire
faire la volonté
des dieux
et la chair joue
contre ça.
Mais c'est intéressant,
l'impératif,
c'est marcher
selon l'esprit
et vous n'accomplirez
pas les oeufs
de la chair.
Verset 18,
cette traduction
qui pour plusieurs
d'entre nous,
c'est si vous êtes
conduite par l'esprit,
elle serait mieux
traduite
si elle était
comme vous êtes
conduite par l'esprit,
vous n'êtes point
sur la loi.
OK ?
C'est la même chose
à quoi il va revenir
plus tard,
car ce qu'il vise
à produire
chez les Galates,
c'est pourvu
que vous êtes nés
de nouveau,
habitation du Saint-Esprit
et que la chair
n'a pas de chance
pour surmonter
toute cette puissance
qui vous est pourvue
par la régénération
et par la présence
du Saint-Esprit,
marcher en conformité
avec ce qui vous êtes.
Arrêter
des données,
écoute
aux interférences
d'une vision
tordue
de la sanctification,
menace
de perdre
les saluts
d'un côté
ou,
par exemple,
vous voir
comme des malades,
coupabiliser
trop les circonstances,
car la réalité,
c'est que
celui qui est en vous
est infiniment
supérieur
à toute opposition
à la production
du fruit
de l'esprit.
la vision
biblique
par rapport
à la sanctification
des chrétiens,
elle est beaucoup
plus positive.
Je vais utiliser
les mots
sans avoir la volonté
de les faire,
mais optimiste,
mais là,
ce n'est pas une question
hasardeuse,
d'optimisme,
c'est une question
de réalité,
d'assurance,
car c'est Dieu
qui assure
la réussite
de tous ses enfants.
et donc,
la réalité ici,
c'est qu'il y a
cette opposition,
mais les côtés
qui ont la victoire
assurée,
vaincante,
ils doivent s'engager
à respecter
ces impératifs,
marcher selon l'esprit.
C'est l'impératif
afin de voir
la résistance
à la chair
réussir
et afin de voir
les fruits
de l'esprit
porter.
Donc,
nous devons
être néanmoins
conscients
de cette bataille,
attention,
l'illustration
et le langage,
c'est le langage
d'une bataille
d'agriculture.
Les mauvaises herbes
qui poussent
la chair chez nous,
constamment
en train d'avoir
leur désir satisfaire.
La chair
qui est en principe
corrompue
envers les mâles,
mais la chair
qui cherche
l'occasion aussi
de l'aspect
le plus animal
et le moins noble
de l'être humain.
Et voilà pourquoi
des fois,
les circonstances
peuvent rendre
encore plus difficiles
qu'on porte
les fruits
de l'esprit
ou elles peuvent
rendre les circonstances
que la tentation
soit plus forte
à satisfaire
les désirs
de la chair.
Les circonstances
ne sont pas
et ne semblent pas
très favorables
à la production
du fruit
de l'esprit.
on a la chance
de retomber
pour les chrétiens
ça doit être
toujours
qu'il y ait
ponctuellement
dans les oeuvres
de la chair.
L'idolâtrie,
la magie,
l'inimitié,
les querelles,
les jalousies,
les animosités,
les disputes,
les divisions,
les sectes,
l'envie,
l'ivronnierie,
les acceptables
et les choses
semblables.
On a déjà consacré
beaucoup de temps
à comprendre
de quelle manière
parfois
les circonstances
arrivent
et comment
l'interférence
et c'est ça
qui est important
à remarquer
la chair
au-dedans de nous
ok ?
De l'autre côté
à l'extérieur
les mauvais enseignements
les faux prophètes
animés
des faux esprits
des mauvais esprits
et parfois même
les circonstances
qui peuvent jouer
pour que nous ayons
l'impression
d'être
moins favorables
à la production
du fruit de l'esprit
ou plutôt
plus favorables
à céder
aux tentations
de la chair.
Et au lieu
de chercher
à nous excuser
devant cette bataille
qui est affreuse
nous devrions
plutôt
nous rappeler
et mettre
toute notre emphase
sur les côtés
tout puissants
qui sont
dans notre équipe.
Donc
il faut remarquer
avant tout
tout l'investissement
des dieux
envers notre réussite.
Et là
nous voyons
l'œuvre parfaite
du Christ
à la croix
on voit
Dieu ne pourrait pas
investir
si tant
sans s'assurer
de la réussite
on voit
l'envoi
du Saint-Esprit
pour habiter
définitivement
chez nous
on perçoit
une nouvelle volonté
une nouvelle nature
et nous sommes
rassurés
de marcher
dans la bonne direction
de la réussite
et c'est surtout
cette assurance
qui renouvelle
aussi en nous
dans des périodes
difficiles
l'espoir
d'être restauré
dans la foi
et de nous délivrer
du manque
du fruit
de l'esprit.
Et donc
cette bataille
elle est illustrée
de cette manière
et nous voyons
dans l'histoire
des Galates
les mêmes problèmes.
qu'est-ce qu'on voit
dans l'histoire
des Galates
des chrétiens
d'origine païen
à nouveau
attention
ils n'avaient pas
un arrière-plan
juif
ils ne connaissaient pas
l'Ancien Testament
à fond
les lois
cette culture
ces pratiques
ils n'ont pas eu
besoin
de devenir des experts
dans l'Ancien Testament
pour apprendre
à mener une vie
plus belle
plus sainte
à ne pas pratiquer
les œuvres de la chair
à produire
les fruits
de l'esprit
de manière très naturelle
à partir du moment
de leur conversion
ils produisaient
les fruits de l'esprit
car ils ont été
greffés à Christ
par la foi seule
Christ a été présenté
par l'apôtre Paul
avec clarté
comme placardé
entre vous
devant vos yeux
si on revient là
dans les passages
et le Saint-Esprit
a scellé
cette conversion
par un réveil
incroyable
l'apôtre Paul
il était assuré
de la conversion
des Galates
car l'œuvre
du Saint-Esprit
était évidente
dans cette église
on n'a aucune mention
des dons de l'esprit
en Galates
mais nous avons
la certitude
que c'était une église
marquée par les fruits
de l'esprit
par la présence
du Saint-Esprit
et c'est là
où Paul était
convaincu
avez-vous
reçu
les Saint-Esprit
par les œuvres
de la loi
par votre performance
religieuse
par la danse
de la pluie
qui veut faire tomber
les Saint-Esprit
à nouveau
en répétant
les déclarations
d'un prédicateur
en n'est pas
manquant
les mercredis
du réveil
ou tout simplement
par les crises
qui avaient été
placardées
par la prédication
devant leurs yeux
spirituelle
et les Saint-Esprit
a été reçu
et Paul peut dire
à propos des Galates
vous avez
commencé
tellement bien
comment vous couriez
si bien
courir bien
selon l'apôtre Paul
c'est de manifester
les fruits de l'esprit
qui vous a arrêté
et voilà les problèmes
de la même manière
que
la prédication
fidèle
par un homme
rempli
du Saint-Esprit
a été honoré
par l'œuvre
du Saint-Esprit
généreuse
dans une communauté
qui marchait
à pleine force
envers la sainteté
des hommes
animés
par un mauvais esprit
par l'esprit
de l'anathème
les légalistes
les judaïsants
a conduit
les Galates
qui étaient
en pleine force
en pleine santé
en courant très bien
à s'affler
bien dans la foi
donc nous n'avons pas
les mêmes privilèges
tous
des Galates
ça devrait être
les paramètres
principaux
ça devrait être
les plus communs
pour les vraies églises
c'est-à-dire
des hommes remplis
du Saint-Esprit
qui proclament
la vérité
avec fidélité
et notre conversion
la conversion
de la plupart
d'entre nous
dans un environnement
fidèle à la parole
et la présence
de Saint-Esprit
expérimental
palpable
entre nous
une expérience
des conversions
et des réveils
si on peut dire
comme ça
mais la réalité
c'est que
plusieurs églises
semblent avoir
beaucoup plus
sous l'impact
avoir été
beaucoup plus
sous l'impact
des judaïsants
des faux prophètes
et c'est vrai
que plusieurs d'entre nous
ont du mal
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
à comprendre
ce qu'est notre nouvelle
identité
notre nouvelle nature
comment la sanctification
fonctionne
et pour plusieurs
d'entre nous
c'est un oasis
lorsque
même dans un environnement
corrompu
on s'est converti
vraiment
et le Saint-Esprit
nous guide
envers un bon pâturage
et c'est la réalité
des Galates
mais c'est aussi
l'histoire de l'Église
et c'est aussi
l'histoire
de notre parcours
des fois
car peut-être
que les raisons
des lentes
oscillations
dans la foi
ne soient pas
forcément
des mauvaises influences
des groupes
hérétiques
au sein de l'Église
des mauvais enseignements
mais ça peut être aussi
à cause
d'un relâchement
spirituel
une négligence
manque des diligences
pour préserver
et cultiver
l'œuvre
du Saint-Esprit
dans nos vies
donc plusieurs raisons
peuvent contribuer
donc Lloyd-Jones
il va présenter
une raison
qui vraiment
devrait nous effrayer
c'est que quand on regarde
l'histoire de l'Église
cette oscillation
on la voit dans l'histoire
des moments où l'Église
elle est visitée
par les Saint-Esprits
d'une manière très généreuse
et qu'elle a un impact
énorme dans la société
où les personnes
ont beaucoup de courage
à proclamer l'Évangile
à partager l'Évangile
et qui ont un impact
même dans la société
mais
le problème
c'est qu'après avoir
été si favorisé
par une œuvre généreuse
du Saint-Esprit
on s'accommode
on n'est pas
diligent à préserver
par les moyens ordinaires
cette relation
avec le Saint-Esprit
et on finit
pour penser
que nous devons
toujours dépendre
des actions
très extraordinaires
du Saint-Esprit
pour garder
notre bon témoignage
donc l'apôtre Paul
il rappelle
les débuts
des Galates
mais il fait
une exhortation
aux Galates
de préserver
leur nouvelle identité
avec la bonne diligence
ils sont appelés
à produire
les fruits
malgré les circonstances
difficiles
qu'ils traversent
aujourd'hui
et donc c'est important
de nous rappeler
de cette emphase
car la question principale
à la fin des comptes
pour la sanctification
bien sûr
que la question principale
pour les saluts
c'est comment
devenir
croyant
mais la question principale
pour la maintenance
ou le développement
ou la restauration
d'une bonne santé
spirituelle
n'est pas
comment devenir
ou redevenir
chrétien
mais
suis-je
un nouvel arbre
si nous sommes
la grande question
pour nous
c'est si l'oeuvre
ou les fruits
du Saint-Esprit
ont déjà été
manifestés
dans ma vie
de manière authentique
si nous avons déjà
expérimenté
cette assurance
solide
qu'à la fin des comptes
attention
les fruits de l'Esprit
comme on a déjà vu
c'est la révélation
des Christ
à nous
de manière expérimentale
à la source
de l'être
et c'est aussi
la manifestation
des Christ
en nous
c'est cette union
vitale avec Jésus
où
il devient
notre plus grand plaisir
et notre plus grand plaisir
devient aussi
limité
être en conformité
avec lui
et donc
les fruits de l'Esprit
est essentiellement
une union
tellement vitale
à Christ
qui non seulement
il produit en nous
une connaissance
expérimentale
mais il produit
également
sa vie
dans nos membres
depuis
notre être intérieur
les fruits de l'Esprit
est une évidence
nécessaire
et suffisante
pour identifier
un vrai héritier
du royaume
des dieux
et nous avons déjà
pour nous aider
à évaluer
nos âmes
considérer
plusieurs caractéristiques
du fruit de l'Esprit
afin
d'évaluer
si nous pouvons
l'identifier
dans nos vies
je vous rappelle
et je vous exhorte
à revenir
sur les prédications
qui sont enregistrées
les quatre
considérations
qu'on a déjà fait
c'est que les fruits
de l'Esprit
sont organiques
c'est à dire
ils découlent
naturellement
de notre nouvelle nature
dans l'Esprit
donc attention
c'est organique
car
c'est un fruit
étant greffé
à l'arbre
qui est Christ
nous qui sommes
une branche
nous allons produire
nécessairement
les fruits du Christ
car
c'est organique
c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on doit faire
c'est quelque chose
qui nous sommes
et qui se manifeste
dans nos vies
les fruits de l'Esprit
il y a aussi
spirituel
c'est les fruits de l'Esprit
il ne peut pas être produit
par des efforts
zoomants
je ne dois pas chercher
à manifester
les fruits de l'Esprit
pour être sauvé
je dois identifier
dans ma vie
la réalité
de cette spiritualité
qui a été engendrée
par ma connexion
avec le Saint-Esprit
donc c'est l'Esprit
qui produit
c'est pas moi
mais c'est
moi
par l'accueil
des influences
du Saint-Esprit
qui manifeste
les vertus
qui sont ici citées
donc quand on lit
l'amour
la joie
la paix
la patience
la bonté
la bénignité
la fidélité
la douceur
et la tempérance
nous ne sommes pas
devant des vertus
naturelles
humaines
nous sommes devant
un caractère spirituel
ce qui devient
encore plus clair
quand on considère
les troisième aspects
il est indivisible
c'est à dire
nous ne sommes pas
devant les fruits
pluriels
nous sommes devant
le fruit
donc il y a
l'intégrité
des caractères
c'est une question
des personnes
c'est Christ
révélé à nous
et Christ
manifesté en nous
c'est une compréhension
spirituelle
et expérimentale
de l'évangile
c'est de comprendre
par exemple
que cet amour
c'est l'amour
qu'on a goûté
salvateur
du Christ
l'amour
des dieux
envers nous
la joie
d'avoir été
réconcilié avec dieux
donc c'est la joie
suprême
c'est une patience
qui est similaire
à la patience
qui Dieu a exercée
contre nous
donc ce sont des vertus
qui ne peuvent pas
être exercées
pour un non-chrétien
pour plus d'efforts
qu'il fasse
et donc c'est une question
d'intégralité
ou d'intégrité
des caractères
et donc même si
dans certaines phases
dans nos vies
certaines de ces facettes
se manifestent
plus faibles
que les autres
elles sont toutes
interdépendantes
et doivent toutes
se manifester
à la une
et une autre
une autre caractéristique
qu'on a considéré
c'est que
ce fruit
est permanent
ok
on a vu
que ça a été toujours
la plus grande promesse
de l'Ancien Testament
envers la nouvelle alliance
c'était
que les Saint-Esprit
soient répandus
que la loi des dieux
soit inscrite
dans nos cœurs
c'est cette habitation
du Saint-Esprit
qui produit
ces fruits
donc c'est permanent
car le Saint-Esprit
devient permanent
chez tous les vrais chrétiens
et donc
comme le Saint-Esprit
a pour but principal
de former Christ en nous
et de révéler Christ en nous
c'est lui qui est
la source suprême
d'assurance
de notre foi
il est décrit
dans la Bible
comme les prémices
et les gages
de notre héritage
donc si Dieu
qui ne peut pas mentir
il a déjà promis
nous donner
le Saint-Esprit
et Christ nous a promis
qu'il serait permanent
dans nos vies
c'est encore
redoubler cette assurance
car Dieu a voulu
sceller
notre conversion
notre alliance
l'assurance
de notre conversion
par la présence
du Saint-Esprit
qui produit ces fruits
qui sert
des gages
pour notre héritage
donc si Dieu
a voulu nous donner
un gage
une certitude
une assurance
il a donné
le Saint-Esprit
donc quand on considère
la Sainte Seine
on verra
c'est aussi
une espèce
d'alliance
des gages
un saut
qui fonctionne
de manière expérimentale
nous exerçons
de manière symbolique
notre foi
par la prise des éléments
qui ont reçu
de la part
de Dieu
mais Dieu
il est par les ordonnances
en train de sceller
notre foi
sauf que
les sauts
des ordonnances
n'ont pas d'efficacité
et particulièrement
pas d'efficacité
expérimentale
si le Saint-Esprit
n'est pas là
en train de donner
du sens
à tout ça
et donc la réalité
c'est que
le Saint-Esprit
est la signification
essentielle
de cette assurance
et donc
devant
tous ces
tous ces attributs
du fruit
de l'Esprit
nous nous approchons
du dernier
qu'on va considérer
de la dernière
vérité générale
à propos du fruit
avant
dans les prochaines
prédications
avant
de considérer
chacune
de ses facettes
l'amour
la joie
la paix
etc
et pour l'instant
les derniers aspects
c'est que pour plus
que les fruits
de l'Esprit
et la présence
du Saint-Esprit
soient permanentes
chez tous les chrétiens
elle doit être
néanmoins
cultivable
et là
j'avais hâte
d'arriver
sur ces points
car nous devons
reconnaître
dans ces passages
toute l'emphase
impérative
donc
nous savons
qu'il y a
plusieurs questions
qui sont évoquées
lorsqu'il y a
une tendance
un peu
philosophique
on essaye
de tout
comprendre
et de tout
expliquer
mais la Bible
elle nous communique
les choses
de manière
suffisamment
claire
et suffisamment
répétée
pour qu'on ne puisse
pas
nier
plusieurs
facettes
de la vérité
même si
parfois
on n'a pas
la capacité
de tout
concilier
parfaitement
quand on pense
au fait
qu'il est
que le Saint-Esprit
est celui
qui opère
les vouloirs
et les faire
comment pouvons-nous
concilier
cette déclaration
avec les versets
d'avant
développer
votre assurance
votre salut
pardon
avec diligence
donc la Bible
qui nous appelle
à être responsable
et diligent
par la manière
dont on doit
cultiver
ses fruits
et la relation
avec le Saint-Esprit
c'est la même
qui nous assure
que nous ne pouvons
qu'il faire
car la volonté
et les faire
dépendent
du Saint-Esprit
donc il y a
ces rôles
permanents
du Saint-Esprit
qui exercent
une influence
constante
sur nos vies
la constance
la plus assurée
de nos vies
heureusement
c'est car
le Saint-Esprit
ne va jamais
désister
d'un vrai converti
donc cette influence
elle est là
elle s'exerce
constamment
sur nos vies
mais
il nous faut
nous rappeler
que ce n'est pas
une influence
comme on a l'impression
d'être perçu
par certains
cercles évangéliques
comme si le Saint-Esprit
était une énergie
vous voyez
quand je parle
de la danse
de la pluie là
c'est en pensant
à certains cercles
évangéliques
de nos jours
qui pensent
pouvoir
produire
l'opération
ou la dynamique
du Saint-Esprit
par la répétition
de certains rites
de certaines phrases
et qui ont
un rapport
envers le Saint-Esprit
comme si le Saint-Esprit
était plutôt
une force
une énergie
et pas une personne
une personne
a des interactions
personnelles
intelligentes
variables
discernibles
la relation
avec le Saint-Esprit
est l'intimité
avec une personne
je ne peux pas
penser
que le Saint-Esprit
soit comme
les secrets
comme cette pensée
positive
post-moderne
moi
un avec l'univers
qui envoie
des vibrations
positives
et le plus
ma mentalité
envers le Saint-Esprit
c'est qu'il va faire
quelque chose pour moi
les choses vont se passer
dans ma vie
ce n'est pas
de mettre
les dieux
la troisième personne
de la Trinité
les Saint-Esprit
Dieu Saint-Esprit
contre le mur
et déclarer des choses
pour qu'il fasse
certaines choses
dans ma vie
pour qu'il sponsorise
mes désirs charnels
parfois
le Saint-Esprit
étant une personne
il a un objectif
fixé pour nos vies
un objectif
suprême
révéler Christ
à nous
former Christ
en nous
vous êtes avec moi
c'est ça son ministère
principal
il va réussir
par contre
le fait qu'il soit
une personne
permanente
en nous
assure
que dans ses relations
envers nous
il fasse usage
de toute sa sagesse
en tant que Dieu
omniscient
pour contrôler
les circonstances
au dehors de nous
et nous aider
à comment répondre
à ces circonstances
sous ses influences
les Saint-Esprits
après les baptêmes
amènent Christ
au désert
pour être tentés
par les diables
les Saint-Esprits
pourquoi
ils ne pourraient pas
les faire avec nous
les Saint-Esprits
qui veulent former
Christ en nous
nous conduit
à travers
plusieurs épreuves
afin de former
Christ en nous
c'est celui
qui porte
les châtiments
d'un Père
qui aime
afin que nous
participions
à sa sainteté
d'où
vient
ce désir
de ne pas
accepter
la souveraineté
du Saint-Esprit
dans les circonstances
de nos vies
si ce n'est
de la chair
du monde
et du diable
et traiter
le Saint-Esprit
comme une force
afin de changer
les circonstances
pour être toujours
préservé
dans un confort
qui ne produira
pas les fruits
du Saint-Esprit
dans nos vies
donc c'est intéressant
parce que la Bible
insiste
sur la souveraineté
des dieux
dans notre salut
il faut remarquer
les contextes
en général
c'est les contextes
d'un Pierre
déçu
avec lui-même
en se sentant
disqualifié
et qui a besoin
d'une assurance
pour pouvoir
surmonter
ses frustrations
avec ses propres efforts
c'est comme si
Jésus disait à Pierre
moi je fais confiance
à ma puissance
je t'ai confié
mes brébis
malgré
ta faiblesse
car j'ai fait confiance
dans ma capacité
de te rendre
plus utile
plus juste
plus sang
de rebondir
sur cette chute
pour devenir
encore plus sang
dans le futur
ce sont des contextes
où l'église
est sous persécution
il pense
qu'elle sera
supprimée
par les circonstances
et la Bible
porte cet encouragement
en disant
c'est lui
qui a commencé
l'oeuvre
va l'amener
à terme
résister jusqu'au sang
vous n'avez pas encore
résisté jusqu'au sang
comme les Christs
comme les nouées
des témoins
vous comprenez ?
la Bible ne nous présente
jamais
l'aspect
souverain des dieux
dans notre salut
et dans notre
sanctification
pour qu'on soit
relâché
envers les péchés
ah non
si le Saint-Esprit
c'est lui
qui opère tout
je vais attendre
jusqu'à ce qu'il
me scientifie
ma bataille
contre la chair
elle est dure
je suis faible
c'est ma faiblesse
c'est mon sang
italien
mes accès
de colère
c'est comme mon père
me traitait
quand j'étais petit
nouvelle créature
les choses
anciennes
sont passées
il n'y a pas
des chambres
des guérisons
des phases
de chercher
à guérir
des choses anciennes
nouvelles créatures
d'une fois pour toutes
et tout puissant
habite en vous
et donc
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
les effaces bibliques
pour restaurer
le courage
pour animer
celui
qui est comme
la canne brisée
Dieu va compléter
l'oeuvre
il pourvoit
les vouloirs
et les faire
c'est pour ceux
qui sont honnêtes
envers leur faiblesse
et leur incapacité
de s'essentifier
Dieu comment
peux-je
surmonter
cette difficulté
dans ma vie
c'est lui
qui opère
les vouloirs
et les faire
il a préparé
d'avance
pour que vous
marchiez
dans ses oeuvres
vous comprenez
et donc
nous ne devions
jamais
mettre
en
contradiction
la Bible
ne les met
jamais
en contradiction
la souveraineté
de Dieu
et la responsabilité
de l'homme
la responsabilité
c'est quelque part
la diligence
les moyens
à travers lesquels
Dieu va accomplir
ses buts souverains
c'est-à-dire
pour que je progresse
dans ma sanctification
je dois participer
diligemment
à cultiver
ma relation
avec le Saint-Esprit
à résister
aux appels
de la chair
c'est ça
la vision biblique
de la sanctification
vous n'avez
aucune excuse
pour vous dire
que c'est plus fort
que vous
aucune excuse
pour dire
que les moments
où je
je sentirais
cette influence
extraordinaire
pour me sanctifier
j'essaie récent
car l'exhortation
ici
est impérative
bien sûr
que parfois
par la grâce
des dieux
nous sommes bénis
par des saisons
ou nous sommes
en train
de navirer
avec les vents
du Saint-Esprit
et parfois
c'est contre
les circonstances
qu'on doit continuer
de faire ces efforts
et donc
comment cultiver
les fruits de l'Esprit
j'espère que ça soit
vraiment très pratique
à partir de là
les fruits
l'Esprit
dans un contexte
où la Bible
nous présente
la bataille
entre
les appels
de la chair
les mauvaises herbes
et les fruits
de l'Esprit
de l'autre côté
les fruits
surtout par
l'exhortation
et l'impératif
à cultiver
à marcher
est quelque chose
de clairement cultivable
et donc
c'est à nous
de participer aussi
pour les cultiver
la première chose
qu'on doit savoir
pour cultiver
les fruits de l'Esprit
c'est que nous devons
développer
une soumission
obéissante
ou une foi
qui fait confiance
envers ces impératives
du Saint-Esprit
il faut renverser l'ordre
les ministères
de Saint-Esprit
qui rend service
gracieusement
à nous
ne diminue pas
sa position
d'autorité suprême
en tant que Seigneur
vous êtes avec moi
il n'est pas
à service
de mes désirs
charlés
et si la Bible
est en train
de me présenter
cette influence
en terre
la rédivabilité
est très proche
les Seigneurs
Saint-Esprit
Dieu 3 fois 100
qui habite en moi
qui exerce
des influences
internes
mais qui exerce
aussi des influences
objectives
donc qui est
l'auteur
des écritures
Dieu
le Saint-Esprit
c'est lui
qui a inspiré
tous ces auteurs
et lorsqu'il
la Bible
m'est dit
lorsqu'il est
Saint-Esprit
nous dit
par la peine
de l'apôtre Paul
marcher dans l'esprit
je dois lire
comme si c'était
le Saint-Esprit
lui-même
c'est la réalité
qui me le dit
marcher dans l'esprit
peu importe
quelles soient
les circonstances
de nos vies
peu importe
si c'est facile
ou non
c'est qu'il exige
la conception
la plus essentielle
de la foi
c'est que la joie
est toujours
la conséquence
de la sanctification
et de l'obéissance
vous êtes avec moi
la conception
essentielle
de la foi
c'est de nous
confier à Christ
et démontrer
notre confiance
en Christ
en obéissant
à ses commandements
ceux qui a
mes commandements
et qui les gardent
ce sont ceux
qui m'aiment
c'est pas pour
conquérir les saluts
c'est pas une obéissance
qui conquérit les saluts
mais c'est une obéissance
qui exprime
les vrais saluts
vous êtes avec moi
donc quand je lis
des passages
comme celle-ci
à partir de verset 13
vous êtes appelés
à l'esprit
à la liberté
donc ne faites pas
impérative
de cette liberté
en prétexte
de vivre selon la chair
mais rendez-vous
impérative
par la charité
serviteurs
les uns des autres
il n'y a pas
trop de limites
qu'on doit s'imposer
pour préserver
les bien-être
afin de servir
avec une meilleure disposition
c'est rendez-vous
par la charité
serviteurs
les uns des autres
car toute la loi
marchez selon l'esprit
impératif
et vous n'accomplirez pas
les désirs de la chair
car la chair
a des désirs contraires
à ceux de l'esprit
et l'esprit
a des contraires
à ceux de la chair
ils sont opposés entre eux
afin qu'ils vous
ne fassiez
ce que vous voudriez
verset 18
si vous êtes
conduits par l'esprit
vous n'êtes point
sur la loi
verset 22
mais les fruits
de l'esprit
donc voilà
ce qui veut dire
marcher
dans l'esprit
c'est produisez
les fruits de l'esprit
l'amour
la joie
la paix
la patience
la bonté
la bénéglité
la fidélité
de soeur
tempérance
produisez
manifestez
les fruits
qui vous êtes
déjà en mesure
de produire
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
verset 25
si nous vivons
par l'esprit
marchons aussi
selon l'esprit
ne cherchons pas
une veine gloire
donc là
il y a plein
d'impératif
au chapitre 6
vous verrez
que Paul va reprendre
cette notion
de cultiver
s'aimer pour la chair
ou s'aimer pour l'esprit
et la réalité
c'est que la première chose
qu'on doit considérer
c'est qu'il contenait
devant des passages bibliques
qui nous présentent
la souveraineté
des dieux d'un côté
et la responsabilité humaine
Philippiens 2.12
bien aimé
comme vous avez toujours
obéi
travaillez à votre salut
avec crainte
et tremblement
non seulement
comme en ma présence
mais bien plus encore
maintenant
que je suis absent
car c'est Dieu
qui produit en vous
les vouloirs et les faire
selon son bon plaisir
c'est vouloir
que le Saint-Esprit produit
est un vouloir
définitif
au moment de la conversion
et aussi
une dimension
où par ses influences généreuses
il rénovalent
un coeur bien disposé
à faire sa volonté
mais la volonté
la plus profonde
de tous les chrétiens
c'est de faire
la volonté de Dieu
voilà pourquoi
parfois on est très attristé
car on n'a pas été
suffisamment ferme
pour satisfaire
les demandes
les plus sublimes
de nos âmes
ensuite
c'est important
non seulement
de considérer
cette manière
dont le Christ lui-même
a décidé
de produire ses fruits
en nous
d'accueillir
ses exhortations
ses impératifs
et nous devons les faire
et ça c'est vraiment
très intéressant
des manières
à accueillir
et cultiver
les influences
attention
immédiates
et les influences
médiées
du Saint-Esprit
comment le Saint-Esprit
il agit
des fois
de manière
immédiate
et palpable
quand on considère
les expériences
des réveils
qu'on a déjà pu
traverser dans nos vies
dans une certaine mesure
dans des mesures
différentes
toutes nos histoires
ne sont pas
vécues
avec la même intensité
dans notre relation
avec le Saint-Esprit
mais tous les vrais
chrétiens
doivent avoir
connu
une intensité
expérimentale
réelle
suffisante
et la réalité
c'est que la Bible
nous présente
dans certaines époques
de nos vies
dans la Bible
dans l'expérience
des fois
de plusieurs chrétiens
ce sont rares
les moments
où ils ont
des expériences
très extraordinaires
des visitations
de la part des dieux
ou du Saint-Esprit
donc on pense par exemple
les moments où Moïse
va se rencontrer
avec Christ
préincarné
dans les buissons ardents
on peut penser
dans la réforme
des Josias
ou des Némi
où il y a un réveil
collectif
on peut considérer
que même
les seigneurs
Jésus Christ
pendant toute sa vie
il y a eu deux occasions
très importantes
dans son ministère
où dans les moments
du baptême
il y a une visitation
particulière
du Saint-Esprit
une manifestation
de l'amour
de la part des dieux
voici mon fils bien-aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
et à la montagne
de la transfiguration
et la réalité
c'est qu'on les voit
aussi
dans les nouveaux testaments
lorsqu'il y a
dans la Pentecôte
les Saint-Esprits
descend
mais même
les personnes
qui avaient déjà
reçu les Saint-Esprits
à plusieurs reprises
dans la Bible
sont appelées
ou sont décrites
comme en ayant été
remplis à nouveau
de Saint-Esprit
où
ils ont
régagné
les courages
et donc
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que dans l'histoire
de l'Église aussi
on peut penser
au grand réveil
ce vécu
par John Wesley
ou George Whitefield
Jonathan Edwards
et plusieurs
d'autres moments
dans l'histoire
de l'Église
soit dans la perspective
individuelle
dans notre parcours
des fois
soit dans l'histoire
de l'Église
de manière collective
la Bible
elle est remplie
et l'histoire
de ces moments
forts
où le Saint-Esprit
il agit
par un réveil
lisez la biographie
par exemple
de Blaise Pascal
de sa conversion
ou de Jean Calvin
lui-même
et vous allez remarquer
l'importance
de ses expériences
capitales
avec le Saint-Esprit
pour toute la suite
de leur ministère
et par la manière
dont ces choses
ont maximisé
leur service
leur persévérance
et leur assurance
et donc
dans les langages
d'agriculture
quand on pense
à ces visitations
du Saint-Esprit
le Saint-Esprit
répandu
de manière généreuse
nous devons considérer
ces moments
de réveil
comme en étant
comme
la saison favorable
donc là
on sait très bien
car les saisons
sont très marquées
ici
en Europe
et lorsqu'il est
printemps arrive
que le soleil apparaît
on voit comment
ça peut accélérer
mais des fois
même hors saison
un coup de soleil
peut faire fleurir
certaines fleurs
aussi
donc ça nous fait
comprendre
que les Saint-Esprit
parfois
exercent une influence
très généreuse
immédiate
ou même
dans des saisons
très difficiles
à contre-courant
l'Église
et les chrétiens
ont la capacité
de produire
beaucoup de fruits
les fruits de l'Esprit
de manière incroyable
nous savons très bien
certains d'entre nous
qu'on a déjà traversé
des moments plus difficiles
des circonstances
plus difficiles
dans nos vies
et au lieu d'échouer
comme c'est le cas
peut-être aujourd'hui
on a pu
en souriant
traverser
des difficultés
encore plus fort
quelle est la distinction
principale
cette influence
de Saint-Esprit
mais le Saint-Esprit
n'agit pas
de manière immédiate
tout simplement
dans les moments
de réveil
si le Saint-Esprit
qui est une personne
habite en nous
tous les chrétiens
et ça c'est vraiment
l'un des principaux
problèmes
avec
une réaction
exagérée
à des mouvements
charismatiques
et surtout
néo-charismatiques
qui réclament
être l'objet
principal
du travail
de Saint-Esprit
lorsqu'il y a
la compréhension
du ministère
de Saint-Esprit
n'est pas biblique
et même
la manière
de gérer
les dons
pour ceux
qui croient
dans la continuité
des dons
n'est pas non plus
biblique
et la réalité
c'est qu'en réagissant
de manière très forte
aux mauvaises expériences
ou aux fausses expériences
l'autre partie
de l'Église
parfois
elle devient
tellement réticente
aux influences
du Saint-Esprit
que c'est comme si
elle négligeait
elle ignorait
ce qu'il est Saint-Esprit
en train de faire
dans leur vie
donc il faut faire
beaucoup d'attention
et la réalité
c'est qu'il est Saint-Esprit
il est à l'origine
par exemple
de cette envie
de prier pour quelqu'un
de penser très fort
à une personne
un membre de l'Église
lorsqu'on est
dans notre moment
de dévotion
de prière
ou si jamais
on se réveille
dans la nuit
avec quelqu'un
dans la tête
ça peut être
tout simplement
les fruits
de notre imagination
ok
et ça peut être
tout simplement
le Saint-Esprit
le même
qui a dirigé Paul
qui a aidé Paul
à interpréter
même si cette tempête
ces vents orientaux
était une manière
du Saint-Esprit
démontrer
qu'il devrait
changer le chemin
nous devons être
très critérieux
pour ne pas réclamer
l'interprétation
inspirée
pour ne pas dire
devant les personnes
les Saint-Esprit
m'a dit
mais nous devons
savoir accueillir
les enfants
du Saint-Esprit
l'Ordjan
il disait
si jamais
pour un prédicateur
tu as des réflexions
vraiment très particulières
l'illumination
d'une compréhension
biblique
prends vite fait
un stylo
et un cahier
car tu ne sais pas
si le Saint-Esprit
va te rappeler
ces choses après
si jamais
dans la journée
tu as envie
de prier
hors de rien
mettez-vous
à genoux
tout de suite
car cette invitation
du Saint-Esprit
ne peut pas revenir
au long de la journée
être gêné
par un péché
traverser
des circonstances
difficiles
et se demander
si c'est ou non
lié à un péché
commis
est-ce que le Saint-Esprit
n'a pas la liberté
d'agir
en parfaite conformité
à son ministère
tel qu'il est décrit
par sa parole
s'il habite en moi
et s'il est une personne
qui pourrait l'empêcher
d'agir comme une personne
envers moi
donc les influences
immédiates
du Saint-Esprit
sont trouvées
partout dans la Bible
si jamais
on est en train
de partager
l'évangile
avec quelqu'un
on ne savait pas
par où
commencer la prédication
l'évangélisation
et d'un moment
à l'autre
on se sent
tellement aidé
par le Saint-Esprit
que on commence
à dire les choses
avec beaucoup plus
de fluidité
promesse du Christ
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
sur les ciels
et sur la terre
allez donc
c'est des disciples
de toutes les nations
et moi
je serai avec vous
tous les jours
et comment on ressent
cette fraîcheur
la présence du Christ
en nous
car il a promis
qu'il s'est lui
les consolateurs
qui habiteraient en nous
nous rappellerait
les choses
qu'on devrait dire
donc
qu'on a
l'interprétation
apostolique
inspirée
des influences
qu'on pense
en tir
de Saint-Esprit
mais si cette influence
est biblique
si elle ne peut pas
venir de Satan
je dois agir
je dois répondre
je dois accueillir
l'influence
de Saint-Esprit
si ça va
dans la direction
de l'amour
de la joie
de la paix
de la bonté
de la bénignité
je dois accueillir
et promouvoir
mais non seulement
les influences
immédiates
de Saint-Esprit
en reconnaissant
notre fragilité
et faiblesse
pour les discerner
par contre
nous sommes surtout
appelés
à être
diligents
et constants
dans les influences
médiées
du Saint-Esprit
quels sont
les moyens
des grâces
par lesquels
le Saint-Esprit
travaille dans nos vies
c'est d'être
là où
le Saint-Esprit
a surtout
l'habitude
de travailler
où il nous a fourni
les outils
les plus importants
pour travailler
dans nos vies
et donc
la Bible
elle est très claire
c'est le Saint-Esprit
qui a inspiré
la parole
c'est l'Esprit
des dieux
qui nous unit
à Christ
surtout
en nous aidant
dans la prière
quand on n'a pas
les mots
donc on doit être
diligent
et garder
notre poste
et cultiver
cette relation
cultiver
les fruits
de l'Esprit
à la fin
c'est de cultiver
la relation intime
avec le Saint-Esprit
dans son livre
à propos du réveil
Lloyd-Jones
il parle
de ces passages
où Jacob
va revenir
vers les puits
d'eau
qui ont été
fermés
par les Philistines
Abraham était déjà mort
et les besoins
c'était
un besoin essentiel
l'eau
et Lloyd-Jones
il prend ces passages
pour décrire
la situation
de l'Esprit
aujourd'hui
les besoins
il est tellement
essentiel
les besoins
numéro un
de l'Esprit
c'est de préserver
et cultiver
la relation
avec l'Esprit
de Dieu
c'est de revenir
à Actes
chapitre 1
où Jésus dit
ne sortez pas
de là
si Dieu
vous n'êtes pas
révéti
du Saint-Esprit
et vous serez
mes témoins
courage
pour proclamer
la vérité
au travail
dans une génération
qui déteste
le prosélytisme
Dieu l'aime
regardez les pages
d'Actes
des apôtres
tous
s'opposaient
à eux
Rome
les juifs
toutes les autorités
mais ils prêchaient
ils proclamaient
la vérité
qu'est-ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui
c'est pas
une meilleure contextualisation
!
ce n'est pas plus
des sophistications
intellectuelles
ce n'est pas plus
d'influence politique
ce qui nous manque
c'est
Saint-Esprit
donc qu'est-ce qui fait
Jacob?
il revient
pas pour présenter
des nouveautés
à l'Esprit
la solution
pour que l'Eglise
grandisse
dans notre génération
lui revient
aux besoins essentiels
il avait besoin d'eau
heureux l'homme
qui médite dans la loi de l'éternel
jour et nuit
son plaisir
est dans la loi de l'éternel
comme un arbre
planté près
d'un courant
d'eau
et donc même lorsque
nous ne ressentons pas
ces influences immédiates
dans nos vies
de manière très claire
la bonne saison
nous devons garder
notre poste
pour protéger
ces jardins sacrés
qui est notre relation
avec le Saint-Esprit
la chair
elle maximise
la tentation
quand on traverse
des moments difficiles
on a beaucoup
de responsabilités
dans nos vies
et parfois
on traverse
des saisons
où les demandes
dépassent
tout simplement
notre capacité humaine
animale
de satisfaire
tous les besoins
dont on pense
qu'on serait
plus en mesure
de vivre
une vie plus équilibrée
de manifester
plus facilement
les fruits de l'Esprit
car les demandes
surmontent
ma capacité
de tenir
solution
de l'Eutère
parce que je sais
que ma journée
sera chargée
je me réveille
deux heures
plus tôt
car la seule manière
de préserver
les fruits de l'Esprit
c'est de protéger
ces jardins sacrés
c'est de ne pas
laisser bouger
les temps
des consécrations
à la parole
à la prière
à l'Église
au conseil
des chrétiens
car les Saint-Esprit
lorsqu'il est cultivé
ses fruits
se manifestent
dans nos vies
beaucoup plus facilement
même hors saison
j'aurais aimé
avoir mon agenda
parfait
pour que je puisse
consacrer aujourd'hui
avec tant d'enfants
les temps qu'il faut
pour chaque enfant
pour faire la dévotion idéale
comme j'imaginais un jour
et c'est impressionnant
parfois
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
travaille
dans ma dévotion personnelle
les choses sont rendues
beaucoup plus faciles
et fluides
dans la journée
des occasions
qui n'étaient pas programmées
deviennent
une œuvre fluide
du Saint-Esprit
la patience
qui s'épuise
plus facilement
revient
quelle est la solution
de ne jamais
nous éloigner
du courant d'eau
comprenez
la responsabilité
qui peut pointer
un homme des dieux
qui a tombé
dans sa
pleine force spirituelle
quelqu'un a déjà dit
personne
ne tombe
tous glissent avant
David
les temps
qui les rois sortaient
pour faire la bataille
ils restent à sa maison
il n'était plus à son poste
!
Cultiver
les fruits de l'Esprit
c'est la plus grande assurance
pour la maintenance
cultiver la relation
intime
avec le Saint-Esprit
c'est la plus grande assurance
pour la maintenance
de la manifestation
du fruit de l'Esprit
donc ici c'est très important
de savoir
que nous devons cultiver
les influences
immédiates
et cultiver aussi
les influences
médiées
du Saint-Esprit
donc nous avons
la Bible
la prière
les conseils
donc regardez
l'effet
du ministère
de l'apôtre Paul
chez les Galates
un homme rempli
de Saint-Esprit
qui a enflammé
dans les bons sens
l'Esprit
et en même temps
la mauvaise influence
des hommes
motivés
par des mauvais esprits
qui a arrêté
les progrès
de cette Église
Ephésiens chapitre 4
l'état de santé spirituelle
des anciens
son impact
pour équiper
les membres
et tous les membres
qui s'édifient
l'Église
ce n'est pas au hasard
que d'habitude
si vous êtes dans une Église
en bonne santé
avec des membres responsables
les mêmes gènes
qui vous sentez déjà
que les Saint-Esprit
produisent dans vos cœurs
vis-à-vis
à une décision
lorsque vous cherchez
les conseils
la multitude des conseils
difficilement
dans une Église
qui n'est pas charnelle
vous serez encouragé
à marcher
envers les péchés
et malheureusement
parfois
on voit
comment les personnes
qui veulent surtout
avoir
une perspective
très
sentimentale
du ministère
du Saint-Esprit
ils sont déterminés
à marcher vers la chair
en ignorant
les conseils
que les Saint-Esprits
portent
à travers l'Église
donc tous ces moyens
de grâce
ils sont vraiment
très importants
dans notre foi
on va devoir
s'arrêter ici
pour célébrer
encore un moyen
de grâce
que les Saint-Esprits
utilisent
qui sont les ordonnances
et nous allons
continuer à considérer
les fruits de l'Esprit
et comment les cultiver
la semaine prochaine
on va